yeah welcome to this video playing black
against some ski from the UK very high
rated we gotta Trump and I have no idea
about this um I recently looked up this
opening and the book by Boris a broke
the default sidelines book very very
good book as usual buy him from quality
chest and he recommends this funny way
of playing with the word retreating 206
and it's it transposes to UM set up
watches normally reach them with the
London system but like lost the tempo
but he says okay I know it loses the
tempo but the setup is so harmless it
doesn't matter alright well as at least
say I'm like it doesn't have any any
troubles I hope so at least yeah I don't
know who this guy is got very very high
rating probably some secondary account
by a by title player of course the [ __ ]
or ski is played by many many British
players after Julian auction maeda made
a living out of this in the 80s and 90s
played the Trump all the time with the
great success okay he went to e hive
with the with his night I'm not sure so
sure what what the point is he can
exchange a couple of couple of pieces
but it's not they're not really
dangerous
yeah probably should should remove the
King John he cannot take on c5 yes if
either saying he can play the night to
d3 maybe in some way but okay I simply
need to get rid of those pieces in the
middle and it's it's a very solid
structure than black this double points
of course are something to look yeah to
to pay attention to but it's not done
not a big issue one thing is he might
take on play Queen a3 threatening to to
tell to do a taxi five I wonder am
probably make I can go here baby I'm
play rugby five protected and then play
Queen evade
seaforth is really a problem Mon guess
it isn't and also i have the idea to
play c4 yeah this should be equal don't
think this is much going on
maybe move like be three but so I'd
making any progress here doubt that
that's very equal what the idea see for
maybe one possible
put it back I mean that's simply not
much going on c4 I cosplay look before
yeah some lift for the king
yeah should I drop back again this what
about a form safe or maybe maybe an idea
I don't so I like to have my queen
unprotected on d6
ah yeah of course he can takes you five
this is a this is a bit annoying or
claim oh this hmm
you like it let's exchange all that nice
got rock d7c 557 ours annoying okay I'm
so look before maybe York before Roxy
six
yeah this was a really bad play by me
I don't really see a way to equalize
this again
now you can go look c6 is a problem
you
can't be form and then a three years I
hope on the side gives me some counter
play but it's not greater obviously
check
yeah these are the on the clock but I
have some plain out the edge porn king
of form I can take with check
I can I can we push the pawn time
morning John probably i cannot play for
well yeah maybe I'm I don't think so I
mean I'm lucky to have a draw anyway so
yeah it is it is it wrong that was
awesome okay oh I was winning at some
point before and then aged 30 just wins
we have all my 20 seconds but that this
would have been fun to to basically seal
this game but of course it was it was a
would have been quite via to to win it
yeah i forgot about the seafoam here
when i went back with the with the Queen
I can play I play other things here and
I don't know Queen somewhere can be a
dome
he I could also take i was i was
thinking about the head this uh yeah but
it it's also not not entirely equal not
entirely evil yeah maybe i can push here
and then a five maybe it's still a draw
yeah well a draw at the end thanks for
watching